moi j'adore le café et il y a tellement
de façons de préparer à travers le monde
partout dans le monde le café fait
partie du quotidien de bien des gens
les italiens sont passés maîtres dans
l'art du parfait expresso
mais chaque région du monde à sa façon
de l'ain fusées et de le servir
le café c'est pour accueillir les ans
j'étais quelqu'un qui tapent à la porte
de ses concurrents café
nous débutons notre voyage en ethiopie
berceau de la caféiculture la légende
veut qu'un berger a remarqué que ces
chèvres étaient excités après avoir
mangé les grains d'un arbuste des
prêtres craignant les effets excitants
de ces gré les jeter au feu pour s'en
débarrasser c'est ainsi que ce n'est la
torréfaction du café bien sûr c'est là
une des multiples versions de l'histoire
cafard c'est la province l'art ou le
café était découvert que fait un cap à
c'est l'origine du café c'est pour ça
que tout le monde et il a fait
les éthiopiens tories fille au fur et à
mesure les grains de café vert puis les
droits le plus finement possible
la mouture est ensuite déposée
directement dans une carafe en terre
cuite rempli d'eau et porter à
ébullition
on fera monter et descendre trois fois
l'infusion une fois que c est prête on
le laisse reposer pour que toutes les
particules de décence mairie où se
déposent au fond et une fois que ces
déposées pendant que en fin de service
dit à fait
traditionnellement le service se fait au
sol sur un plateau surélevé et ont fait
brûler un peu dansant pour l'ambiance
on peut le parfumer avec soin du
gingembre soit du canada c'est une
faille alms du coup son équipier du bar
qui était de parfumer est lui-même avec
beaucoup de prises et du sel santé
[Musique]
au vietnam on le prend comme un café où
on le prend classés parce que
évidemment
la glace locale et au bois de la glace
le principe est simple quelques
cuillères de lait condensé sucré au fond
du verre puis on fait percolé le café
dans un filtre les vietnamiens préfère
le café robusta qui est amer et plus
caféine et pour la taxe à dreux puis
quand ça finit relève qu' on le branche
ferment les cons lancé avec les cachets
qui orages de la glace
parfois on va utiliser un café aromatisé
au chocolat
alors comment dit-on santé carl icahn
les
way c'est ce que ça goûte à café
iphone merci nous avons à faire
découvrir si massa
mon ami automne explique moi à quoi nous
avons affaire ici et ici on a affaire
avec le café libanais comme vous voyez
ici ça c'est une machine qui était
importée de la turquie au sam le pote
qui s'appellera quoi qu'on utilise pour
méditerranée un peu à la manière
éthiopienne on ajoute le café moulu
extrêmement fins directement dans leur
acura contenant de l'eau on porte à
ébullition sur la plaque chauffante le
sable servant de catalyseur on va
commencer dans pas longtemps voir le
café qui commence à monter
déjà c'est super on obtient une danse
ici à pas d'extraction comme l'espresso
l'eau passe pas l'eau vraiment est
brouillé avec l'écran de cafés au monde
et très fins plus souvent en privé juste
le café réguliers et ça a commencé aussi
d'introduire le café à la saveur de la
cardamone qu'on est horrifiée avec les
grands du café si jamais je m'essayer
qu'est ce que je demande comme types de
café les grès qu'on importe du liban sud
du brésil à 80 % ça vient du brésil
c'est comme arabica brésilien
la cloche en train de prendre un café
turc avec du café brésilien est un ami
libanais ouais c'est bon ça sent comme
ça
[Musique]
ça c'est régulier sans la cabane
ouais mais c'est bon le jeu le juste le
cérémonial sur ce très sympathique il
est dit que ce soit dans le sable chaud
ça nous amène
absolument après cette courte viry
caféine et je suis prêt à affronter la
journée